or jesse bonsoir bonsoir quoique on peut
le dire on se connaît on se connaît très
bien être un bon pilote moto exactement
tu m'a raconté ce qui était arrivé ouais
je voulais qu vient de témoigner ce soir
ouais voilà un métier riche n'a pas
pleuré à arette messi parce que c'est ce
qui était arrivé tu peux a dû raconter
un mois
voilà c'est le témoin de la semaine
[Musique]
on soir jesse bond soir alors vous avez
44 44 et lorsque vous avez huit mois
votre maman fait une tentative de
suicide en se défenestrant du 4ème étage
se sort les tabous place et malgré votre
très jeune âge vous est ballotté de
nourrissons nourris oui c'est pas facile
comme des bus depuis sa non salées pas
effectivement mais vrai c'est une
période que dont je me rappelle pas
parce que gt gt et gt tout petit j'étais
un bébé donc effectivement peut-être ça
a créé des chez moi puisque des choses
inconsciente d'une forme d'instabilité
mais je me rappelle pas cette période
véritablement c'est des souvenirs
communs indiqué tout simplement et puis
à l'âge de 3 ans vous place dans une
famille d'accueil en normandie et c'est
là que vous allez vivre un enfer ouais
le mot enfer et c'est peu de le dire
pour un enfant tout cas en fait j'ai été
placé dans une famille d'accueil dans
l'orne dans le 61 et on m'a placé la
barre bien entendu parce que quand vous
êtes un enfant de la dass vous êtes
forcément un enfant traumatisé et quand
on vous place dans une famille c'est
pour qu'on puisse vous soigner dans
cette famille déjà quant à l'enfant est
placé la dass exige qu'il ait une
chambre pour lui donc j'avais ma chance
après il ya tout le côté affectif qui
est nécessaire tous âges en étaient
dépourvus j'avais rien ça veut dire que
dès 3 ans je devais rester dans ma
chambre tout seul
vous sortez que pour manger
on m'a plus jamais par nos prénoms mois
toujours appelé par mano famille camara
d'accord
j'avais malheureusement par rapport aux
autres enfants de la famille ils avaient
tous j'avais rien tout le temps au
quotidien j'avais des maltraitances le
classique c'était le martinet l'accord
ou alors on me laissait en mettant à
genoux sur une grille un paillasson
métalliques ça fait super man le métal
sur le genou la sensation avec les mains
sur la tête c'est horrible on faisait ça
dès 6 ans 7 ans 8 ans il ya cet épisode
où enfant vous vous réjouissez de
d'aller à la kermesse oui effectivement
c'est c'est à dire que les enfants
maltraités new hope is all i c'est un
classique et moi je faisais pipi au lit
et un jour à la soulever ma couverture
elle avait une auréole elle m'a tirée
par les cheveux à m'acheter la salle de
bains
elle m'a forcé à tapis pillant les
toilettes elle a pris un bol à la
ramasse et le pipi m a demandé de le
boire elle s'élève c'est là c'est la mer
qu'ils appellent la mère la mère de ma
famille d'accueil c'est elle qui était
chargé de s'occuper de celle qui vous
faisait subir toutes ces violences oui
oui tous ces violences ça venait d'elle
et dont je regarde le bois je la regarde
et elle me dit ira pas là car même si tu
bois pas j'ai vu j'ai bu j'étais à la
kermesse ont fait boire de l'uriné ont
fait taper dans l'écueil pieds nus le
fait manger ton mouchoirs on m'a fait
manger mon mouchoir thierry un mouchoir
en tissu les bons mouchoirs d'époque
pour ce mot chez notre morve tu vois ce
mouchoir j'avais fait un noeud j'arrive
pas à le défaire elle m'a dit de le
défaire thierry j arrivais pas elle m'a
dit tu ne mangeras à midi je sais
qu'elle ne connaît pas j'ai tout fait
pour le défaire j'ai pas réussi à table
devant tous ces enfants avec de la purée
était dans mon assiette elle est partie
dans la cuisine moi je suis un guerrier
j'ai dit ok il faut que je mange
je sais pas comment j'ai réussi à passer
ce que j'ai mis la purée je les mange et
il est passé à l' est revenue à 10000 et
où je les mange et était mort de rire
c'est tous morts de rire mais c'est
assez c'est des sévices parmi tant
d'autres il ya aussi cet épisode ou à
noël vous recevez un comme cadeau un
camion oui oui oui les les enfants de la
terrasse on a cette chance d'abord
l'argent de vêture de l'argent de poche
et on nous donne de l'argent pour
acheter les cadeaux en donne aux
familles il m'avait effectivement acheté
tous mes cadeaux j'étais content j'ai
joué jour de noël sauf que l'engouement
j'avais palois d'y jouer et c'est quoi
comme cadeau j'avais un accordéon
j'avais un camion à l'espèce de robots à
peu à la colle thaurac est donc ce
qu'elle a fait c'est que j'ai jamais
compris pourquoi d'ailleurs
c'est qu'elle est primé jouer les avis
dans le placard mural en eau dans ma
chambre mais l'avait c'est la clé donc
est ce que je faisais moi
discrètement je devrais je montais sur
les deux étagères et je jouais au hockey
om surprennent que je puisse vite me
dégager entre son lit j'étais pas qu'on
jeu vous savez quand vous êtes harceler
jeunes vous êtes aux aguets tout le
temps vous démerder comme vous pouvez
pour chercher votre liberté et votre
moment de plaisir d'accord ça je n'ai
jamais perdu et donc un jour à ma
surprise
elle m'attire et elle m'a jetée sur le
lit à la prime est joué
la mise à jeter dessus un camion a tapé
sur mon genou âme à sectionner tous
jeunes ou ma cicatrice la porte encore
aujourd'hui c'est un v j'avais 8 ans
elle a pris mais jouer à les acheter par
la fenêtre mais jouets de noël se sont
explosés dans le sol j'ai couru toute ma
vie derrière ses jouets je suis content
tu peux raconter
[Applaudissements]
combien j'ai si je tenais à vous offrir
un cadeau aujourd'hui
je voulais vous offrir un camion c'est
comme ça
voulez vous offrir le camion avec lequel
vous auriez jouer avec de l'insouciance
pendant toute votre enfance parce que je
sais que témoigner pour vous aujourd'hui
c'est la première fois oui et parce que
c'est symbolique oui on va l'appeler le
camion de la résilience est voilà donc
merci
[Applaudissements]
de fait
la masse
[Musique]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous y mettez un peu
de bleu